OUR ATKINS BATES BACKER FORTUS
BRADFORD CABALLERO CORTES E.
DOWLING DODD TORONTO EGGMAN
GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE HERTZBERG
WESO FOR TADO JONES KAMLAGER
LAYERED LEYVA THE MON MCGUIRE.
MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
SHOW OF VOGUE PAN PORTANTINO ROF
RUBIO SKINNER STERN- BURKE BY
CAL SKI WIENER. WILK THANK YOU
MA'AM SECRETARY WITH THE MEMBERS
AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL
AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY SENATOR GONZALEZ
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING AND WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR WITH. CENTER GONZALEZ
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IN THE
FIFTEENTH CENTURY THE VENERABLE
SORT ONE OF THE CRUZ SAID I
DON'T STUDY TO KNOW MORE BUT TO
IGNORE LESS GRACIOUS AND
MERCIFUL GOD TODAY WE THANK YOU
THAT TODAY'S LATINO SPIRIT AWARD
EASE HAVE NOT IGNORED THE NEEDS
OF YOUR PEOPLE BUT I'VE USER
EDUCATION AND KNOWLEDGE TO BUILD
UP THEIR COMMUNITIES AND
CONTRIBUTE TO BRINGING JUSTICE
AND PEACE TO OUR WORLD. MAY THEY
CONTINUE TO DISCOVER CREATIVE
AND DARING WAYS TO ENCOURAGE
THRIVING COMMUNITIES MAY THEY
CONTINUE TO WITNESS TO THE
VALUES OF GENEROSITY AND
COLLABORATION FOR THE BENEFIT
ALL RIGHT MAY THEIR STRUGGLES BE
OCCASIONS OF GROWTH AND
TRANSFORMATION OFFERING HOPE TO
OUR SUFFERING ROLES LOVING GOD
MADE ALL THEIR EFFORTS BRING
THEM PEACE AND JOY AS THEY
CELEBRATE THE WONDER AND MYSTERY
OF OUR COMMON HUMANITY WE ASK
THIS IN YOUR NAME. AMEN WHAT.
ISRAEL. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR AND
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
SENATOR BATES. LATER BATES
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
GET MY GLASSES OUTSIDE CONSUMER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY TO HONOR THE PUBLIC
SERVICE AND WELL EARNED
RETIREMENT OF KATHY WILSON HE
BELOVED SENATE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS
STAFF MEMBER FOR TWENTY ONE
YEARS WHEN KATHY FIRST BEGAN
WORKING IN THE CAPITAL SHE CAME
FROM THE WORLD OF MEDIA SHE
STARTED HER PROFESSIONAL CAREER
AS A RADIO NEWS DIRECTOR
REPORTER AND ANCHOR. SHE LATER
WENT ON TO BECOME A DISC JOCKEY
FOR TRANSITIONING TO TELL OF
BEFORE TRANSITIONING TO
TELEVISION FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS
SHE WORKED AS THE HOST AND
PRODUCER. OF A PUBLIC AFFAIRS
PROGRAM FOR A TV STATION IN
CHICO WHERE SHE CREATED AND
PRODUCED THE STATION'S FIRST
MORNING NEWS PROGRAM. KATHY'S
CAREER IN THE LEGISLATURE
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND ONE WHEN
SHE BECAME THE SENATE REPUBLICAN
BROADCAST STUDIOS FIRST IN ONLY
EMPLOYEE. THIS IS NOT STICKING
TOGETHER. THANKS KATHY STARTED
HER CAREER IN MEDIA THE WAY WE
COMMUNICATE HAS DRAMATICALLY
CHANGED WHEN SHE FIRST STARTED
EARLY DAYS OF HIGH DEFINITION TV
AND YES THOSE CLUNKY VACUUM TWO
TV'S ARE STILL AROUND WHEN CATHY
CAME ON BOARD WITH THE SENATE
SHE TAUGHT HERSELF HOW TO EDIT
AND PREPARE MEDIA PACKAGES BUT
S. MEDIA PROGRESS OVER THE
YEARS. KATHY ALSO FOUND HERSELF
ADAPTING TO THE CHANGES THERE
WAS NO TASK TOO DIFFICULT NO
PROGRAM TO NEW IN NO SKILL SHE
COULDN'T LEARN KATHY ISN'T JUST
AN EMPLOYEE OF THE SENATE SHE'S
AN INSTITUTION SHE CREATED AND
GREWA VITAL PROGRAM THAT
RECENTLY SERVICE TWO HUNDRED
PROJECTS A MONTH FOR SENATE
REPUBLICANS NOT ONLY DID SHE
SHAPE THE ROLE OF THE MEDIA.
VIDEO AND TV WITHIN REPUBLICAN
OFFICES BUT SHE ALSO SERVED AS A
ROLE MODEL AND FRIEND TO MANY IN
THIS BUILDING KATHY ALWAYS WENT
ABOVE AND BEYOND FOR THE SENATE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS BECAUSE OF HER
LOYALTY AND DEDICATION SHE
EARNED THE RESPECT OF ALL OF HER
COLLEAGUES BOTH MEMBERS AND
STAFF FOR MENTORSHIP AND
GUIDANCE HAS PROVIDED VALUABLE
GROWS FOR THOSE AROUND HER. HER
ABILITY TO WEAR GRACIOUSLY WITH
OTHERS SERVES AS A MODEL FOR ALL
PROFESSIONAL STAFF IN THE
CAPITAL WELL WE'RE LOSING HER
VALUABLE EXPERTISE IN
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE WILL
CONTINUE TO KEEP HER WITH US AS
A FRIEND AND A MENTOR. SHE IS
GENUINELY A KIND SOUL WERE
CERTAINLY SAD TO SEE HER GO BUT
THIS IS A FOND FAREWELL KATHY WE
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST IN YOUR
RETIREMENT AS YOU SPEND MORE
TIME WITH YOUR FAMILY INCLUDING
YOUR HUSBAND RALPH SON NICK AND
DAUGHTER IN LAW BRANDY AND
GRANDDAUGHTER NIKKI MARIE
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IN EXTENDING OUR DEEPEST
GRATITUDE TO FOR TO KATHY WILL.
FOR HER DEDICATION SERVICE TO
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE. THE NEW JONES THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO WANTED TO
SPEAK ON CAPPIES RETIREMENT
THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR A
KNOWLEDGE IN HER THIS MORNING.
WHEN KATHY FIRST TOLD ME THAT
SHE WAS RETIRING THE FIRST
THOUGHT THAT I HAD WAS ARE YOU
KIDDING ME. YOU CAN RETIRE. I'VE
KNOWN KATHY FOR A LONG TIME FROM
THE ASSEMBLY AND- WHEN I FIRST
CAME UP WITH THE CONCEPT OF THE
ARE YOU KIDDING ME VIDEOS SHE
JUMPED RIGHT ON THAT AND WAS A
CHEERLEADER. AND REALLY- TOOK
UPON HERSELF THE EDITING
RESPONSIBILITIES ANSWER PASSED
ALL OF MINE IN MY STAFF'S. I
EXPECTATIONS- WITH THAT EATING
THOSE VIDEOS AND PUTTING THEM
TOGETHER. SO WHETHER THE PROJECT
WAS AN ARE YOU KIDDING ME VIDEO
A PRESS CONFERENCE A BILL
PRESENTATION. OR WHATEVER ELSE
WE THREW AT HER OFTENTIMES AT
THE LAST MINUTE. HI KATHY ALWAYS
WAS UP FOR THE CHALLENGE AND
ALWAYS PRODUCE A STELLAR WORK.
KATHY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COUNTLESS HOURS OF FILMING AND
PRODUCING THESE VIDEOS. WILL
GREATLY BE BEST BY ME YOU WILL
BE GREATLY MISSED BY ME MY STAFF
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS. MOST OF
MY CONSTITUENTS WHO ENJOY THE
VIDEOS THANK YOU GOD BLESS YOU
AND WE WISH YOU MUCH BLESSINGS
IN YOUR RETIREMENT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER JOHNSON-
NIELSEN. MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE I THINK
I'VE BEEN BLESSED TO DEAL MORE
YEARS WITH KATHY THAN ANYBODY.
IN ORDER COMES TO MIND FOR THIS
WOMAN IS LOYALTY. LOYALTY TO THE
INSTITUTION. DOES SHE WORK FOR
THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS SHE HAS
ALWAYS BEEN LOYAL. TO THE
INSTITUTION. INSTITUTION MAIN
FIRST OF ALL THE STATE SENATE.
AND THE LEGISLATURE THE RULES
AND TRADITIONS HE REFER
STUDIOUSLY AWARE OF. AND HAD
FEEL. TO LONG TENURE KIND OF A
ROCK RARE THING AROUND HERE.
THERE IS A LOT OF TURNOVER.
THANK GOODNESS IT HAS NOT BEEN
THE CASE WITH KATHY. KATHY THANK
YOU FOR THOSE LONG YEARS OF
SERVICE YOUR MENTORING YOUR
PATIENCE IN EUROPE INCREDIBLE
PROFESSIONAL ABILITY GOD LOVE
YOU GOD BLESS YOU AND GOD SPEED
. THANK YOU SENATOR NIELSEN
CERRO TOCO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I AUTHORIZED
TO RECOGNIZE KATHY WILSON. IN
ALL HER REMARKABLE WORK WITH THE
SENATE I MET KATHY LAST YEAR'S
AND NAVIGATED MY FIRST YEAR IN
THE LEGISLATURE. I WAS
IMMEDIATELY IMPRESSED BY HER
PROFESSIONALISM HER WIT AND
KINDNESS HE WELCOMED INTEREST DO
YOU WITH OPEN ARMS NEVER LETTING
ME DOUBT MYSELF AS I READ
THROUGH SCRIPT AFTER SCRIPT SHE
OFFERED GUIDANCE AND PATIENCE.
YOU'RE ENCOURAGEMENT HELPED ME
FEEL EMPOWERED IN YOUR WORK HELP
ME DELIVER STRONG MESSAGES
THROUGHOUT MY DISTRICT. KATHY
YOUR COMMITMENT YOUR WORK SHOW
THROUGH THE COUNTLESS WELL
CRAFTED VIDEOS YOU DRAFTED FOR.
ALL YOUR HARD WORK AND
DEDICATION WILL BE TRULY MISSED
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE OVER
THE PAST TWENTY ONE YEARS.
CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
RETIREMENT. THANK YOU SENATOR
CHAU BOGUE AND THANK YOU AGAIN
MISS WILSON WE ALL APPRECIATE
YOU AND ENJOY YOUR RETIREMENT.
ALL RIGHT MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED WE'RE
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE SENATE RULES THE SENATE
JOURNALS FOR THE WEEK OF APRIL
TWENTY FIFTH TO TWENTY EIGHT.
TWENTY TWENTY TWO WILL BE
APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK. WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE FOLLOWING REYES. WILL BE
PLACED ON TODAY'S SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR ACR ONE
THIRTEEN AND ACR ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. WITHOUT OBJECTION THE
FOLLOWING BILLS WITH FLOOR
AMENDMENTS WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED- ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT FIFTEEN BILL NUMBER
AB FOUR TWENTY ONE. YES THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT NOW WE ARE MOVING
ON TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE WE'RE GONNA START WITH THE
SECOND READING FILE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL ELEVEN TWENTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS THIRTEEN FORTY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS EIGHTY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS ELEVEN FORTY EIGHT
WITH AMENDMENTS ELEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTEEN
NINETEEN WITH AMENDMENTS
FOURTEEN TEN WOMEN MADAM
SECRETARY THE SECOND READING
WILL BE DEEMED READ WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS- CENTER BATES WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE. PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY THREE IS A CONFIRMATION
OF DAVID SCRIBNER AS DIRECTOR OF
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY SERVICES
AND DEVELOPMENT. PRIOR TO THIS
ROLE HE WAS SERVING AS THE
DEPARTMENT'S ACTING DIRECTOR AND
CHIEF COUNSEL HE WAS APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON APRIL
TWENTIETH ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
. SEEING AND HEARING MAN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BECKER AYE FORGES
AYE BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
PROTESTING AYE DALLY. DODD FIVE
THE RUSSELL FIVE EGGMAN. GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I HEARD.
I REQUEST SO. HI FURTADO I JONES
I KAMLAGER LAYERED I LEYVA AYE
LIMÓN. I MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I
A TO A VOTE HI PAM. PORTANTINO I
BROUGHT AYE RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN HI NUMBER I BY CASTING AYE
WIENER. I WILK PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBER. DALLY EGGMAN I
KAMLAGER PAN WELL I THIRTY SIX
NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR SENATOR BATES THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY FOUR IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF TINO JOHNSON
HALL AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY MR JOHNSON HALL HAS AN
EXTENSIVE PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE IN BANKING FINANCE
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND
SERVED ON THE HOUSING FINANCE
AGENCY BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR
SEVEN YEARS BEFORE BEING
APPOINTED AS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
SHE WAS APPROVED IN THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON APRIL TWENTIETH.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BECKER AYE FORTUS
AYE BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO I FOR
TESTING I DALY. DODD I DRAW SO I
EGGMAN HI GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I
GROW. I HERTZBERG FIVE WITHOUT.
HER TADO I JONES I KAMLAGER
LAYERED I LEYVA AYE LIMÓN. I
MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S AYE MIN. I
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN AYE A CHILL
OF BOTH I PAN. PORTANTINO I ROTH
FIVE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. STERN HI
I'M BURKE AYE AYE CASKEY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BALLY WESO I.
KAMLAGER PAN SKINNER I WILK IS
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO SENATE THIRD
READING WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH FILE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT
SENATOR WIENER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL EIGHT
THIRTY SIX BY SENATOR WIENER AN
ACT RELATING TO EVIDENCE IN
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
SECRET MEDIALLY SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A MAN
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES SB THIRTY
SIX MAY SEEM FAMILIAR TO SOME OF
YOUR BECAUSE WE PASSED AN
IDENTICAL LAW SEVERAL YEARS AGO-
WHICH WAS SENATE BILL SEVENTY
FIVE- THAT LAW EXPIRED DECEMBER
THIRTY FIRST WE NOW ARE RUSHING
TO RE AUTHORIZE IT WHAT THIS
LEGISLATION WHAT IT DID AND WHAT
IT WILL DO IT PASSED ON IS TO-
REQUIRE THAT OF SOMEONE IN
CORPORATE ATTORNEY WANTS TO ASK
. ON THE STAND ABOUT THEIR
IMMIGRATION THE FIRST HAVE TO GO
MAKE UP A SHOW TO THE JUDGE THAT
THAT QUESTION IS ACTUALLY
RELEVANT TO THE CASE THAT
CANCERS RANDOMLY OUTSIDE
QUESTION ON WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS
THAT AT TIMES- ATTORNEYS HAVE
EFFECTIVELY HARASSED WITNESSES
ON THE STAND BY ASKING UNDER
IMMIGRATION STATUS EVEN THOUGH
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH ANYTHING
IN THE CASE AND WHAT THAT DOES
IS IT CONVEYS TO IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES BUT IF YOU GO TO
COURT YOU MIGHT GET DEPORTED-
BECAUSE YOU MIGHT HAVE TO ANSWER
UNDERSTAND WHY YOUR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. AND SO YOU HAVE PEOPLE
WHO THEN DON'T WANT TO GO TO
COURT- AND EVEN IF IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES BELIEVE THAT GOING
TO COURT. MIGHT GET THEM
DEPORTED. AND THAT MAKES ALL OF
US LET'S SEE IF WE HAVE.
WITNESSES IN VICTOR WHO ARE NOW
SHOWING UP IN COURT- TO TESTIFY.
TO BE CLEAR IF SOMEONE'S
IMMIGRATION STATUS IS RELEVANT
TO THE CASE THE ATTORNEY SIMPLY
HAS TO MAKE A SHOWING TO THE
JUDGE AND THEY'LL BE ALLOWED TO
ASK A- BUT THIS WILL AND THE
HARASSMENT SIDE- RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER
WINNER MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
M. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA I CAN
AYE BATES. BAKER I PORCHES.
BRADFORD I HAVE A- HI FOR
TESTING HI SALLY. DODD I-
AWESOME I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
REQUEST SOME. HI FURTADO. JONES
KAMLAGER LAYERED I LEYVA AYE
LIMÓN AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ.
MANY AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. BUT
OF BOTH PAN. PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN
AYE I'M BURKE HI KELSEY I WIENER
AYE WILK THIS CALL THE UP
MEMBERS. BATES PORCHES. DALLY
GROVE. HER TADO. JONES KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ NIELSEN PATROL BOAT PAN
WILK. I TWENTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
URGENCY IS TWENTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
FIVE SENATOR CORTESE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL ELEVEN HUNDRED BY SENATOR
CORTEZ SEE AN ACT RELATING TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CENTER CORTESE
THANK YOU WILL PRESENT SOME
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB ELEVEN
HUNDRED TO ENSURE ACCESSIBLE AND
SEE PUBLIC MEETINGS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. ACROSS THE STATE
PUBLIC OFFICIALS AND PUBLIC
ATTENDEES CONTINUE TO DEAL WITH
DISORDERLY CONDUCT DURING
MEETINGS AT SUCH A HIGH
MAGNITUDE THE CRITICAL BUSINESS
AND THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
LOCALLY AS A WHOLE HAS BECOME
IMPAIRED. WE'VE HEARD FROM MANY
LOW GOVERNMENTS TO PUBLIC
OFFICIALS AS WELL AS COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. ABOUT THE NEED FOR
CLARITY ON WHAT AUTHORITY
LEGISLATIVE CAN EXERCISE WITH
REGARD TO REMOVING. INDIVIDUALS
WHO IS WHO ARE DISRUPTING A
PUBLIC MEETING. DUE IN PART TO
THE WIDE RANGE OF DIFFERENT
INTERPRETATIONS OF BY VARIOUS
COUNCILS AND ATTORNEYS WHAT BUT
ACROSS THE STATE. AS WE'V BEEN
SEEN MANY TROUBLING INCIDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE INCLUDING THOSE
INVOLVING HARASSMENT THREATS OF
VIOLENCE HAVE DEMONSTRATED THE
NEED TO PROTECT SAFETY AND
PUBLIC MEETINGS. BY MODERNIZING
THE PRODUCTS SO THAT IT PROVIDES
CLEAR STANDARDS AROUND NGUYEN
REMOVAL THE MANY PARTICIPANTS
WARRANTED IN WHAT AUTHORITY
MEMBERS OF A LEGISLATIVE BODY.
CAN EXERCISE BUT- COMMONSENSE
MECHANISMS TO DE ESCALATE
SIGNIFICANT. AND ALLOW MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATIVE BODY TO
RETURN TO THE IMPORTANT
GOVERNMENTAL BUSINESS. AS
SWIFTLY AS POSSIBLE SB ELEVEN
HUNDRED WOULD ENHANCE PUBLIC
ACCESS TO MEETINGS THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
IN THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU CENTER CORTESE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. CENTER MELINDA'S
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR FIND ME
THIRTIES WHO TAKE A QUESTION YES
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU-
SENATOR CAN'T. LOCAL BODIES
ALREADY TODAY HAVE SOMEONE
REMOVED FROM A MEETING IF
THEY'RE BEING EXCESSIVELY
DESTRUCTIVE. YES THE SHORT
ANSWER IS YES BUT- THEN WHY DO
WE NEED THIS BILL. WOULD BE YES
THE SHORT ANSWER IS YES- BUT
THERE'S AMBIGUITY IN THE LAW AND
WE HAD TWO EXCELLENT DISCUSSIONS
AT THE COMMITTEE LEVEL AS TO
WHERE THIS BILL CLEARS UP THE
AMBIGUITY. ON WITHOUT HIM
IMPACTING OF THE CONTENT OF THE
SPEECH THAT THAT INDIVIDUALS
WOULD OTHERWISE PROVIDE- DURING
A MEETING- IT IT GIVES IS
ESSENTIALLY- CLEARER DEFINITION
TO COUNTY COUNCILS IN IN CITY-
ATTORNEYS IN TOWN. ATTORNEYS
LIKE IN THE TOWN OF LOS GATOS OF
MY DISTRICT WHERE. THEY WORK
CLEAR EVEN THOUGH A SCUFFLE WAS
GOING ON- AS TO. AT WHAT POINT
THEY COULD RECESS MEETING AT
WHAT POINT- THEY CAN CONTINUE
THEIR BUSINESS WITHOUT THE
PRESENCE OF FOLKS WHO WERE
TRYING TO DISRUPT THE VARIOUS-
ABILITY OF THE MEETING TWO
TICKETS TO BE CONTINUED AT THAT
POINT- THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
MEMBERS FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
HAVE SERVED IN LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MANY OF. MANY OF YOU HAVE YOU
KNOW FULL WELL THAT- OFTEN TIMES
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS PRESENT PRESS
THE CITY COUNCIL MEETINGS AT
BOARD OF SUPERVISOR MEETINGS
EVEN SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS. AND
YOU KNOW THAT THE RESOURCES ARE
AVAILABLE TO BOARD MEMBERS TO
COUNCIL MEMBERS TO HAVE SOMEONE
REMOVED FROM THE MEETING IF THEY
ARE BEING EXCESSIVELY
DESTRUCTIVE IF A SCUFFLE IS
BREAKING OUT MOST CERTAINLY. LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN INTERVENE AND
HAVE THOSE PEOPLE REMOVED AND
CERTAINLY IS WITHIN THEIR
PURVIEW TO RECESSED THE MEETING
UNTIL THEY CAN GET IT UNDER
CONTROL IN RE CAN MEET SO THAT
IS ALREADY ESTABLISHED STATE LAW
WITH THIS BILL- I WORRY DOES IS
SENDS A MESSAGE. TO SCHOOL
BOARDS AND CITY COUNCILS AND
FORTY SUPERVISORS MEMBERS THAT
IF ANYONE COMES FORWARD IN
DISAGREES WITH THE POSITION OF
THE BOARD MEMBERS OR HAS- AND
YOU KNOW SOME GRAPE THAT THEY
WOULD LIKE TO AIR IN PUBLIC.
THAT THAT GIVES LICENSE TO THESE%
MEMBERS TO SAY YOUR BEING
DISRUPTIVE PLEASE HAVE THIS
PERSON REMOVED FROM THE MEETING
AND THEY WILL HAVE THE STATE
BACKING UP BEHIND THEM THE WIND
WILL BE AT THEIR SALES IF WE
PASS THIS BILL. I WANT TO JUST
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON THE FACT THAT
IT SAYS- AS A DESCRIPTION. OF
WHAT THE DESTRUCTION WOULD BE IT
SAYS TO ENGAGE IN BEHAVIOR.
DURING THE MEETING OF A
LEGISLATIVE BODY THAT ACTUALLY
DISRUPTS DISTURBS IMPEDES OR
RENDERS INVISIBLE SO I AM VERY
CURIOUS AS TO- WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO CLASSIFY AS DISTURBS. I
DISRUPTING ME WITH WITH THAT YOU
KNOW A FATE IS ONE THING BUT TO
DISTURB MEETING SOUNDS RATHER
SUBJECTIVE TO ME AND I WOULD ASK
YOU. TO RECONSIDER. YOUR YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL KNOWING
THAT PARENTS ACROSS THE STATE
WANT TO HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD
WHETHER THAT IS AT A SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING OR A CITY COUNCIL
MEETING OR WORK OR EVEN A WATER
DISTRICT MEETING. BUT WITH THE
LAST THING THEY WANT IS TO BE
SHUT DOWN BY THEIR STATE
GOVERNMENT WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY
WHAT THIS BILL IS GOING TO AND I
CAN PROMISE YOU. THE RESULTS
WON'T BE FAVORABLE TO YOU THANK
YOU I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
CENTER MELINDA'S MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NINE CENTER CORTESE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I DON'T
THINK ABOUT A PRESIDENT AND I
WOULD JUST EMPHASIZE- IN THE
PORTION OF THE BILL THAT WAS
JUST READ THE WORD ACTUALLY IT'S
VERY CLEAR THAT- THE LEGISLATIVE
MEETING OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT HE
WOULD HAVE TO ACTUALLY BE
IMPEDED THE- BEFORE. THE
ACTIVITIES WOULD WOULD TAKE
PLACE BY THE PRESIDING OFFICER
OF THE BOARD I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
CORTESE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. AYE
BATES. NO BAKER I PORCHES NO
BRADFORD I HAVE A FIVE
PROTECTING FIVE DALLY. DODD AYE
DURACELL AYE EGGMAN. I GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG I REQUEST SO. ARE YOU
FURTADO I JONES NO KAMLAGER
AIRED I LEYVA AYE THE MON AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ NO MAN I
NEWMAN. I NIELSEN NO CONTROL
OVER NO HAN PORTANTINO. I ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN FIVE
NUMBER FIVE WHAT KIND OF SKI I
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL
NOPE THERE WE GO I JUST TWENTY
NINE NO SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY TWO SENATOR MEN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY SIX
BY SENATOR MEN RELATIVE TO
ANNIVERSARY OF LOS ANGELES RIOTS
CENTERMAN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I TODAY I RISE TO SENT
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY SIX
WHICH RECOGNIZES THE THIRTIETH
ANNIVERSARY THE LOS ANGELES
RIOTS AND UPRISINGS WHOSE MEMORY
STILL LINGERS ON PARTICULARLY IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THE LOS AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA. I'LL A
SOPHOMORE IN HIGH SCHOOL IN A
CALIFORNIA SUBURB WHEN THIS-
RIGHT OCCURRED I REMEMBER
WATCHING THE VERDICT COME DOWN
AND BEING SHOCKED BY THIS
WATCHING THE RIOTS BREAK OUT.
AND I THINK FOR ME AS A KOREAN
AMERICAN. I WAS THE FIRST TIME I
REALLY STARTED UNDERSTAND THE
RADIATION FRUSTRATION HELD BY
OUR- BLACK COMMUNITIES OVER
CENTURIES OF HISTORY IN THIS
COUNTRY OF SUBJUGATION. AND
SYSTEMIC RACISM. I AND I THINK
I'LL ALSO. RELEASED START TO
CONNECT THE DOTS ON ON HOW- THE
GREEN COMMUNITY. NEEDED TO BE
ENGAGED IN I THINK IS A LESSEN
THE MANY KOREAN AMERICANS TOOK
AWAY FROM THESE RIGHTS THAT. WE
COULDN'T JUST KEEP OUR HEADS
DOWN AND- FOCUS ON THE SUCCESS
OUR BUSINESSES ARE OUR OWN
DEALINGS THAT WE HAD TO
PROACTIVELY ENGAGE GET INVOLVED
IN POLITICS. AND BUILD
COALITIONS WITH OUR NEIGHBORS
WITH OTHER COMMUNITIES- AND
THAT- I THINK WAS A LESSON THAT
EVERYONE TOOK AWAY AT THE RIGHTS
OF COURSE BECAUSE- UNTOLD DAMAGE
THAT WAS CONCENTRATED IN
KOREATOWN. AN ESTIMATED TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED KOREAN RUN
BUSINESSES WERE DESTROYED- MANY
ENTREPRENEURS LOST THEIR
LIVELIHOODS ALL TOLD THAT LOSS
OF PROPERTY WAS ONE BILLION
DOLLARS- BUT THE STORY THE
UPRISING OF COURSE WASN'T JUST
ABOUT DAMAGES ARE LOOTING- IT
WAS- I THINK IT THE SEEDS OF A
DIALOGUE THAT HAS CONTINUED TO
THIS DAY BETWEEN. THE BLACK AND
KOREAN AMERICAN COMMUNITIES IN
LOS ANGELES AND AROUND THE
COUNTRY- AND I WAS PLEASED LONG
SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE IN
THIS ROOM AND IN THE OTHER
CHAMBER. TO ATTEND A NUMBER OF
EVENTS WHERE WE REKINDLE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. AND I THINK IT'S
AN IMPORTANT CONVERSATION TO
THINK ABOUT HAVING TODAY AS WELL
AT A TIME WHEN ANTI ASIAN HATE
IS- SOMETHING THAT DOMINATES OUR
HEADLINES. WHEN WE SEE WITH THE
GEORGE FLOYD IN SO MANY OTHER
INSTANCES OF SYSTEMIC ANTI BLACK
RACISM- I DID THIS PROBLEM
CONTINUES TO BE SYSTEMIC AND
ENDEMIC IN OUR SOCIETY- WE NEED
TO BUILD THOSE COALITIONS WE
NEED TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
. AND S. YOUR NINETY SIX
MEMORIALIZES THE PAIN AND HURT-
AS AS WELL AS THE CONSTRUCTIVE
DIALOGUE THAT WE NEED TO HAVE. I
THINK THIRTY YEARS LATER I THINK
MOST OF US WOULD ACKNOWLEDGE
WE'VE MADE PROGRESS BUT THERE IS
STILL SIGNIFICANT WORK LEFT TO
BE DONE. AND I'M HOPING THAT
THIS RESOLUTION WILL SEND A
SIGNAL THAT. HATE I'M SO- A
SIGNAL THAT- THAT THAT WE TO
HAVE THOSE DIALOGUES- SIGNALED
HOPE IN REUKA. THAT WE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CONTINUE CAN
CONTINUE TO REPAIR THE SCARS.
LEFT BEHIND BY RACIAL
ANIMOSITIES- THAT HAVE DIVIDED
OUR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
CONTINUE TO DO SO TODAY ONLY BY
WORKING TOGETHER IN UNITY WILL
WE BE ABLE TO OVERCOME. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MEN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. CENTER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I'M GOING TO RISE
TO AN WHEN MY VOICE TO
RECOGNIZING THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION AND I REMEMBER
VIVIDLY- WATCHING THAT GRAINY
VIDEOTAPE. OF RODNEY KING BEING
BEATEN WITHIN AN INCH OF HIS
LIFE AND THE ARGUMENT ARE THE
RESPONSE WAS HE WAS RESISTING.
WELL IF A MAN ON THE GROUND LAMB
PROSTATE BEING BEAT BY FOUR
WOULD BELIEVE RESERVE THAT I'M
AFRAID OF WHAT THEY DESCRIBED
MOSIS THAT I DO EVERY DAY
BECAUSE- THIS MAN- IT WAS. IF IT
DID NOT FOR THE FACT. THAT IT
WAS INDIVIDUAL WITH A VIDEO
CAMERA ON HIS BALCONY AND HAPPEN
TO CATCH THIS GRAINY PHOTO-
VIDEO I SHOULD SAY OF THIS. THEY
WOULD THE OFFICE WOULD TOTALLY
LIVE. EVEN THOUGH WE HAD THE
VIDEO THEY LIVE. AND WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THIS IS SPENDING
AND STORE GO PROCTOR'S SPECIALLY
IN THE MINORITY COMMUNITY WHEN
IT COMES OUT AFTER AMERICANS.
AND THE DATE THAT THE VERDICT
CAME THROUGH. I REMEMBER I WAS
CALLED TO FOR CME CHURCH IN LA
ONE OF THE MOST PROMINENT
AFRICAN AMERICAN CHURCHES WERE.
UNITY LEADERS LIKE DAVID- JOHN
MACK OF THE URBAN LEAGUE MAYOR
TOM BRADLEY VARIOUS OTHER
ELECTED OFFICIALS ASSEMBLED
THERE THAT NIGHT. TO DISCUSS HOW
WE SHOULD REACT TO WHAT CLEARLY
WAS AN INJUSTICE BY THE JURY.
AND I REMEMBER LEAVING THAT
CHURCH THAT NIGHT IN CHOOSING
THE TAKE CRENSHAW BOULEVARD HOME
. AND IN A MATTER OF MOMENTS
FROM LEAVING THE CHURCH TO THE
TIME I MADE IT BACK TO GUARDIAN-
I LOST TRACK OF THE NUMBER OF
FIRES THAT I WITNESSED THE
NUMBER OF LOOTING AND RIOTING
AND- AS- ALL RIGHT DESTRUCTION
AND- BUYERS THAT WERE SO HIGH
EVEN THOUGH MY WINDOWS WERE UP I
FELT THE HEAT AS I DROVE DOWN
FRENCH ALL BOULEVARD IN MY
VEHICLE. BUT IT WAS NOT JUST
THAT IT WAS ALL THE PENT UP
ANGER THAT HAS EXISTED IN THE
COMMUNITY ALLEN PRESHEAF MINE
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
FOR. MENTIONING THE UNITY THAT
WE NEED TO COME TOGETHER TODAY
BUT PART OF THAT ALSO WAS THE
KILLING OF A FIFTEEN YEAR OLD
AFTER AFTER AN AMERICAN- GIRL
LATASHA HARLINS JUST MONTHS
BEFORE. SHE WAS BUYING
ATTEMPTING TO BUY. A BOTTLE OF
ORANGE JUICE AND SHE WAS SHOT IN
THE BACK OF HER HEAD. WHAT THE
MONEY IN OUR HANDS. AND BUSH
SHOOTER WAS ALSO ACQUITTED WAS
GIVEN PROBATION THAT WAS PART OF
THE PENT UP ANGER IN THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND EVEN
TODAY MANY OF THOSE PROPERTIES
THAT WERE DESTROYED THE STEEL
SAID VACANT TODAY SO I STAND
HERE TODAY AND HOPING THAT WE
CAN LEARN FROM OUR MISTAKES OF
THE PAST AND UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE'S STILL MUCH WORK TO BE
DONE. R. AS IT RELATES TO A
BETTER POLICE RELATIONS IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR BUT ALSO
BETTER RACE RELATIONSHIPS WITH
THE VARIOUS COMMUNITIES EXIST
AND I WANT TO THANK AGAIN MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE FOR M.
THIS RESOLUTION- COMMUNITIES TO
UNITE AND HEAL. MEMBERS OF ALL
BACKGROUNDS AND ETHNICITIES MUCH
SIXTY IN THE V. BY RECOGNIZE OUR
COMMON HUMANITY AND OUR BASIC
HUMAN RIGHTS AND- ASSURE THE
BLOCK CALL BECAUSE I'M PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM API. CAUCUS AND
THE LATINO CAUCUS RESPECTFULLY-ASK FOR OUR VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING THEN SENATOR MEN WHICH
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES. BAKER I PORCHES. BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO I PROTECTING AYE
DALY. DODD I TORONTO I EGGMAN
AYE GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE WESSEL AYE FURTADO
AYE JONES I KAMLAGER. LAYERED I
LEYVA AYE LIMÓN I MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S FIVE MILLION AYE
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. A TROUBLED I
PAN PORTANTINO. HI ROB FIVE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER I STERN I
NUMBER FIVE CASSIE I WINNER. I
WILK. SKEWS ME PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES PORCHES.
DALLYING GROVE. FIVE KAMLAGER
NIELSEN I. PAN WILK FIVE THIRTY
FOUR NO ZERO THE MEASURE IS
ADOPTED MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM FORTY NINE
SENATOR TO RAZA MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY NINE BY SENATOR ALSO
RELATIVE TO SINGLE TO MY OWN
FEET. SENATOR ALSO THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT IS MY HONOR TO
PRESENT SENATE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY NINE. AS IT MEMORIALIZES
SINGLE THAT MILE AS A
SIGNIFICANT DATE AND MEXICAN AND
CALIFORNIA HISTORY. ON SYNC WITH
MY OWN EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO AT THE
BUT THE OTHER PUEBLA IN MEXICO A
SMALL ARMY OF INDIGENOUS
MEXICANS OUTNUMBERED AND
OUTGUNNED. FORMULATED A STRONG
RESISTANCE AND DEFEATED A FRENCH
COLONIAL FORCE. A FORCE THAT WAS
MUCH LARGER BETTER TRAINED AND
EQUIPPED. THIS RESISTANCE WAS
LED BY BENITO WATERS WHO LATER
BECAME MEXICO'S FIRST INDIGENOUS
PRESIDENT. BY THE SEVERE LACK OF
RESOURCES THE MEXICAN ARMY'S
DETERMINATION TO BE FREE FROM
COLONIZATION MADE THEM
VICTORIOUS THINK OF THE MY-
SERVES TO REMIND US THAT THE
FOUNDATION OF ANY NATION AND OUR
STATE IS ITS PEOPLE. THEIR
SPIRITS THEIR COURAGE IN THE
FACE OF DIVERSITY. LATINOS TODAY
AT THEIR FOREFRONT. AND WHILE
BEING CIVIC ENGAGEMENT HEALTH
FOR ALL ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
PARK SPACE IN THE ARTS AND THE
MOST VIBRANT LABOR MOVEMENT IN
THE COUNTRY WE INVEST IN OUR
CHILDREN REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUSWE REPRESENT
GENERATIONS OF FARMWORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES. WHO PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLES OF AMERICANS ACROSS
THIS NATION. SO ON THIS DAY IN
THE LATINO CAUCUS IS PROUD TO
SHARE WITH YOU THE COURAGE THE
STRENGTH AND RESILIENCE THAT IS
EMBODIED IN NINE LATINO LEADERS
WHO WE HAVE SELECTED TO RECEIVE
OUR ANNUAL SPIRIT AWARD. ASK
BRIANNA VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
DORADO MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE CENTER NIELSEN. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE I ENTHUSIASTICALLY
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION. IN A
HEARTFELT WAY. THEN THE MID
EIGHTIES I HAD REPRESENTED THE
SOLANO COUNTY AND ONE OF THE
CITY'S JUST BENICIA. AND LITTLE
TINY BENICIA HAD A SISTER CITY.
ABOUT SIXTY MILES NORTHEAST OF
MEXICO CITY CALL TO LEARN WHERE
THE- RUINS OF TEOTIHUACAN ARE
THE HISTORIC MAYAN CITY. AND I
SPEAK WHAT I CALL FIELD SPANISH
NOT VERY ACCOMPLISHED BUT I CAN
GET THERE. I MANGLE THE TEXT AND
HAVE TO TALK AROUND TO GET THE
RIGHT WORDS BUT I GET THERE.
WHEN I GO TO MEXICO IT TAKES ME
ABOUT THREE DAYS. TO BE SEMI.
CONVERSANT. BECAUSE FIRST I HAVE
TO THINK MEXICAN. AND EMPATHIZE
WITH THE CULTURE. WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY WONDERFUL. WHAT
HAPPENED TO BE AT THE S. THE
SISTER CITY EXCHANGE EVERY OTHER
YEAR VISITORS FROM ONE CITY WILL
GO TO THE OTHER. ON TWO
OCCASIONS I HAVE TRAVELED WITH
THE NATION DELEGATION THE TOTAL
. AND WE HAPPEN TO BE THERE ON
SINKING TAMAYO. ONE YEAR. ON ALL
THE PAGEANTRY IN THE CEREMONY.
IT'S WONDERFUL. BUT
UNDERSTANDING THE HISTORY OF THE
BATTLE OF PUEBLA. MADE IT MUCH
MORE SPECIAL. AND THE COURAGE OF
THOSE WARRIORS. THE KNOWS YOUNG
MEN WHO FOUGHT. THAT REALLY WAS
MOVING. AND THEY ASKED ME TO.
GIVE A DISCURSO SPEECHIN THE
PLAZA IN THIS DAY IN THIS GREAT
CEREMONY. AND I WAS CAPABLE
ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK FROM
THE HEART. USE THE RIGHT WORDS
ALTHOUGH I PROBABLY DID MANGLES
THE TECHS OR THE TENSES
SOMETIMES. BUT IT WAS A VERY
MOVING OCCASION. AND THE
RECEPTION AFTERWARDS ALSO WAS
LIFETIME MEMORABLE. I CONCLUDED
MY REMARKS. WITH A LARGE FILL IN
ON READY TO LIVE. NOW I'M A MAN
OF TWO. AND I STILL AM ALL THESE
YEARS LATER. AND THIS SPECIAL
HOLIDAY IS MORE SPECIAL TO ME.
BECAUSE OF THAT PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE OF THOSE WONDERFUL
RESIDENTS OF TO THE MEXICO.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON CENTER
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS. I RISE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL
RESOLUTION SEVENTY NINE
RECOGNIZING THAT THE FIFTH DAY
OF MAYES CELEBRATING REFERRING
TO AS WELL CALL SINGLE TAMAYO
SPANISH NAME SINGLE TAMAYO.
THINK OF THE MILES IS A
CELEBRATION OF MEXICAN HERITAGE
THAT COMMEMORATES THE
ANNIVERSARY OF MEXICO'S VICTORY
OVER THE FRENCH EMPIRE AT THE
BATTLE OF PUEBLA ON MAY FIFTH
EIGHTEEN SIXTY TWO. THE MEXICAN
ARMY OF FOUR THOUSAND TROOPS
DEFEATED THE BETTER EQUIPPED AND
LARGER FRENCH INVASION AT
VERACRUZ GIVING MEXICO AND ITS
PEOPLE NOT JUST A MORAL BOOST
BUT A SENSE OF NATIONAL UNITY
AND PATRIOTISM. THE VICTORY. AND
THE VICTORY WAS **** WAS SHORT
LIVED AS THE FRENCH EMPIRE
RETURNED TO FOLLOWING YEAR. THE
MORAL BOOST THIS SENSE OF
NATIONAL UNITY REMAINS EVEN TO
THIS DAY. CIGNA MILE HAS
REMINDED THE MEXICAN PEOPLE AND
THOSE OF MEXICAN HERITAGE THAT
THEIR NATION WAS NOT EASILY
FORGED AND- THAT THEIR ANCESTORS
ACTIONS WERE RIGHTEOUS IN THE
PURSUIT OF INDEPENDENCE OF
NATIONAL UNITY. IN FOR THESE
REGIONS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF S.
R. SEVENTY NINE AND I URGE
EVERYONE TO ENCOURAGE YOUR
FELLOW SENATORS EVERYONE TO
CELEBRATE AND ACKNOWLEDGE THINK
OF THE MILE. AND I URGE AND I
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER ARCHULETA
CENTERMAN. AND PRESIDENT ON
BEHALF OF THE ASIAN AMERICAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF SR
SEVENTY NINE RECOGNIZINGCINCO
TAMAYO. CINCO TAMAYO SHOWCASES
CALIFORNIA'S RICH CULTURAL
DIVERSITY AND IS AN
INSPIRATIONAL REMINDER OF HOW
DETERMINATION HEART AND GRIT CAN
BEAT THE ODDS SOMETHING WE'RE
SEEING PLAY OUT RIGHT NOW IN
UKRAINE. FROM THE LINE OF GREAT
STRIKE TO THE CREATION OF ETHNIC
STUDIES THE API COMMUNITY IS
PROUD OF A LONG HISTORY OF
WORKING WITH THE LATINO
COMMUNITY. TO OVERCOME INK
SEEMINGLY IMPOSSIBLE ODDS TO
FIGHT AGAINST HATE AND
INJUSTICES. WE ALSO WANT TO
CONGRATULATE AND RECOGNIZE THE
AMAZING WORK OF THE RECIPIENTS
OF THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO
LATINO SPIRIT AWARDS. THEIR
DEDICATION AND WORK FOR THE
COMMUNITY IS AN INSPIRATION TO
US ALL. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING OUR PARTNERSHIP AND
SO CELEBRATING CINCO TAMAYO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
SR SEVENTY NINE IN A SPIRIT OF
JOY. THANK YOU CENTERMAN CENTER
SKINNER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS. I RISE ON
BEHALF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS. IN PROUD SUPPORT OF SR
SEVENTY NINE. RECOGNIZING NOT
ONLY SINGLE TOMORROW BUT ALSO
THREE SIXTEENTHS OF THE LATINO
SPIRIT AWARDS. AND THEN AND I
WANT TO NOTE THAT. MANY
IMPRESSIVE WOMEN AMONG THOSE
BEING HONORED. WITH WHICH YOU
KNOW IS NOW MAKING UP THE
LARGEST SEGMENT OF CALIFORNIA
STATE POPULATION. I THINK WE ALL
REALIZE LATINO SUCCESS IS OUR
SUCCESS. AND AS THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS VICE CHAIR I'D LIKE TO
NOTE THAT LATINOS ARE BRINGING
THEIR BEST TO CALIFORNIA AND WE
ARE BETTER FOR IT AMONG THE LIST
LEGISLATIVE LATINO CAUCUS FOR
EXAMPLE. THERE ARE SEVENTEEN
WOMEN LEGISLATORS AMONG THE
TWENTY NINE MEMBERS. BUT AS MUCH
AS LATINOS BRINGS CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT HAS NOT
ALWAYS BEEN THERE FOR THEM.
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE FORCIBLY
STERILIZED LATINOS AS LATE AS
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES IN
DIFFERENT INSTITUTIONS AND
STERILIZATIONS OF LATINOS IN OUR
STATE PRISONS TOOK PLACE EVEN
INTO THE TWO THOUSANDS IT WASN'T
UNTIL TWENTY FOURTEEN THAT WE
BANNED THAT PRACTICE. PANDEMIC
IS ANOTHER CASE IN POINT. IN THE
FIRST YEAR THE PANDEMIC LATINOS
WERE THE BIGGEST DROP IN OUR
LABOR WORK FORCE OF ANY
DEMOGRAPHIC. MANY OF THEM LEFT
THE WORK FORCE NOT ONLY BECAUSE
THEIR JOBS WORK SHUT DOWN BUT
ALSO BECAUSE THEY HAD
RESPONSIBILITY TO TAKE CARE OF
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO NO LONGER HAD
THAT PLACE TO GO BECAUSE THEY'RE
FACILITIES WERE SHUT DOWN. IN
FROM AUGUST TO SEPTEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND THE TEAM
HAS DROPPED OUT OF OUR LABOR
FORCE. MANY WHO'VE NOT YET
RETURNED. AND OF COURSE
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE SO MANY OF
THEM ARE AMONGST OUR LOW WAGE
WORKERS THAT HAS BEEN A SERIOUS
SERIOUS IMPACT FINANCIALLY ON
THEIR FAMILIES. THAT'S WHY I AM
VERY PROUD. THAT WE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED INTO LAW PROTECTIONS FOR
HOSPITALITY WORKERS LAST YEAR.
AND I AM PROUD THAT THE SENATE
HAS ALWAYS PRIORITIZED THE
RIGHTS AND PROTECTIONS FOR OUR
WORK FORCE ESPECIALLY LOW WAGE
WORKERS WHICH AS I. JUST
MENTIONED REMAINS DOMINATED
UNFORTUNATELY BY THE TINA'S IN
OUR SERVICE AND OUR CARE
SECTORS. BUT SINGLE TOMORROW IS
A DAY OF CELEBRATION SAW AND ON
A HIGH NOTE THAT THAT IT
CERTAINLY REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
STRENGTH AND THE FIGHT IN THE
SPIRIT THE LATINOS BRING TO OUR
STATE AND WITHOUT I ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
CENTER BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I TO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A STAR SEVENTY
NINE IN THIS YEAR OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. JUST
WANT TO NOT ONLY RECOGNIZE
SICKLE THE MILE BUT ALSO THE
LATINO SPIRIT AWARD WINNERS WHO
WILL BE RECOGNIZED. ARE TODAY
AND THIS YEAR C. L. B. C.
RECOGNIZE A SINGLE TAMAYO
CELEBRATIONS ARE PART OF THE
VERY FABRIC OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
UNDERSTAND IT IS UP TO ARE YOU.
LIKE THOSE SPIRIT AWARD ORANGE
BEING HONORED TODAY TO CONTINUE
TO KEEP THE RICH HISTORY AND
TRADITIONS OF SINGLE TOMORROW
WEEK ALIVE FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO COME TODAY WE
STAND IN UNITY. BUT WE ALSO
STAND SIDE BY SIDE WITH OUR
LATINO BROTHERS AND SISTERS OF
THE CAUCUS AS WELL AS WITH OUR
NON LATINO PEOPLE WHO CELEBRATE
HISTORIC BATTLE FOUGHT. AND IN
HONOR OF THE YOUNG LATINO SPIRIT
AWARD WINNERS AND THEIR BRAVE
RESOLVE WITH KNOWLEDGE TO HERO
HER HER. ROLE HERE IS. I CAN
TALK TODAY IS A RODEO. THE
RESUME ALL WITH MIXING CITIZEN
THIS WHEN THEY STOOD THEIR
GROUND ON THEIR OWN SAW LINE. WE
MUST ALWAYS REMEMBER THE STRONG
TRADITION SET FORTH BY THE PAST
AND THE WARRIOR SPIRIT UP
TODAY'S FUTURE LOOKING ONLY-
MEMBERS AND LEADERS MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF THE C. L. B. C. I
ASKED FOR A VOTE ON CELEBRATIONS
TO GO TO MY WEEK. THANK YOU
CENTER BRADFORD CENTER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO IS ON ON
BEHALF OF THE L. G. B. T.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS TO CELEBRATE
CINCO DE MAYO DAY- AND I THINK
EVERY. EVERYONE FOR SPEAKING SO
FAR I WANT TO THANK OUR GUEST UP
IN THE CHAMBERS ARE IN STOCK AND
WE HAVE A PROUD HISTORY OF US
INCLUDING MY WAS OUR BIGGEST
PARADE. SO WE JUST HAD OUR BIG
PARADE YESTERDAY ON SUNDAY IT
WAS OUR FIRST ONE SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SO PEOPLE WERE OUT IN
ALL THEIR GLORY I CAN TELL YOU
PEOPLE BEEN BUSY THERE WERE
BABIES GALORE- THERE WERE TACO
TRUCKS THERE WERE PARADES IT WAS
MUSIC THAT WAS BOND AND IT WAS
GONNA BE OUT. THERE WITH MY
IDEOLOGIES- AND THE PRIDE THE
PRIDE BOTH IS RIGHT THERE TOO
WITH A LONG A LINE AS LONG FOR
THE PRIDE WAS AS IT WERE FOR THE
TACO TRUCKS- SO THAT I MEAN
REALLY TOLD ME THAT WE HAVE
EMBRACED. AND CELEBRATED IN FOR
EVERYBODY WHO'S UP THERE GETTING
AN AWARD TODAY WE ALL KNOW SO
MANY UNSUNG HEROES IN OUR OWN
COMMUNITIES EDUCATORS.
ENTERTAINERS YOU NAME IT WERE
ALL OUT THERE AND WHICH IS SO
GREAT TO SEE EVERYBODY IT'S SO
GREAT FOR US ALL TO BE BACK- AND
ON BEHALF OF THE LGBT CAUCUS.
ENCOURAGED AN AYE VOTE ON SR
SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN CENTER GONZALEZ. THANK
YOU MADAM. I TOO WOULD LIKE TO
RISE AND SUPPORTIVE SR SEVENTY
NINE- HAPPY SINGLE THEM PRE
SINGLE THAT MILE AS WELL- REALLY
SHOWS THE STRENGTH OF MEXICAN
CITIZENS AND MEXICANS AND MEXICO
AS A COUNTRY AND- AS THE
DAUGHTER OF AN IMMIGRANT FROM
MEXICO CAN BE EVEN MORE UP.
COULDN'T BE. MORE PROUD TO
SUPPORT IN. THIS RESOLUTION AND
OF COURSE SUPPORT THE LATINO
CAUCUS IN THEIR EFFORT TO-
CELEBRATE LATINO SPIRIT AWARD
DIS. FEMA WE HAVE A FEMALE
PRESIDENT AND CEO AMONG THOSE
ORTIZ AN ENTREPRENEUR. ADVOCATE
AND COUNSELOR OBGYN PHYSICIAN
AUTHOR ENTERTAINER. AWARD
WINNING FILMMAKER. HARDWORKING
UNION PRESIDENT FROM LONG BEACH
VERY PROUD. AND IN MEMORIAM OUR
HOUSING C. E. O. SO. SO MANY
LATINOS PROVIDE SO MUCH TO THIS
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHERE NEARLY
HALF OF THE POPULATION AND I
COULDN'T BE MORE PROUD TO- ALSO
CELEBRATE THEM AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MY GOOD SENATOR FROM
LOS ANGELES FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALEZ CENTER STERN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE ON BEHALF
OF THE LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS- I DON'T EXPRESS MY
SOLIDARITY. AND SUPPORT PRESS
ARE SEVENTY NINE IT'S JUST SO
HAPPENS THAT- MAY FIFTH THIS
YEAR ALSO COINCIDES WITH YOUNG
HEARTS. WHICH IS ISRAEL
INDEPENDENCE DAY AND I THINK
IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT- WHEN IT
COMES TO THE STRUGGLES FOR SELF
DETERMINATION- AND FOR JUSTICE
THAT IMMIGRANTS PLAY A CENTRAL
ROLE- COUNTLESS- JEWS FROM ALL
OVER THE WORLD- LEFT THEIR HOMES
OR WERE FORCED OUT OF THEM
DURING THE HOLOCAUST- TO BUILD
FOR THEMSELVES A HOMELAND AND
YOU KNOW THAT SAME. THAT SAME
SOLIDARITY THAT WE SAW FROM
IMMIGRANTS- AND CALIFORNIANS
DURING THAT CONFLICT WAY BACK
WHEN EVIDENCE IS THAT- THIS
SOLIDARITY KNOWS NO BORDERS AND
DOES SO WITH THAT IN MIND AND
THE SPIRIT OF UTENA SOLIDARITY
IF YOU WILL- RISING SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
DRAWS WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR EVERYONE'S
COMMENTS AND I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. MEMBERS THIS IS
YOU KNOW- ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
SEEING AND HEARING THEM EYES
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE-RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED WE'RE
GOING TO RETURN TO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR AND SENATOR DORADO.
AND SHE IS GOING TO INTRODUCE
OUR LATINO SPIRIT AWARD HONOREES
SENATOR ALSO THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TWENTY
ONE YEARS AGO THAT LATINO
CAUCUS- STARTED THE AWARDS LIKE
THAT LET THE MOST BEARD AWARDS.
AND WE HAVE THEM WITH US TODAY
WE HAD AN EARLIER CEREMONY IN
WINS- THIS CUSTOM MADE
CALIFORNIA BEAR WITH WE CHOI
BEADS. IS ACTUALLY- MADE JUST
FOR OUR HONOREES FROM THE FROM
THE EIGHTIES MEXICO SO- LET ME
START OUT OF WITH. MY IDEA IS
SALINAS. HE IS THE PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THE LARGEST
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION L. A.
COUNTY REPRESENTING TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
BUSINESSES MISTER LINA'S TOOK
THE- HELM OF THE ORGANIZATION IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN HE
BECAME THE FIRST WOMAN. AS A
LATINA THE FIRST WOMAN TO LEAD
THE CHAMBER IN ITS HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO YEAR HISTORY HE'S AN
APPOINTEE TO GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
COMMISSION ON THE FUTURE OF
WORK. AND HAS WAS NAMED TO THE
BUSINESS AND JOBS RECOVERY TASK
FORCE HE SERVES ON THE U. S.
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE COMMITTEE OF
ONE HUNDRED- AND ON AND ON SUSAN
APPOINTEE OF LA MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI. TO THAT MIX LACK
COMMISSION OF FOREIGN POLICY
INITIATIVE BETWEEN MEXICO AND
LOS ANGELES- JOIN ME IN-
HONORING OUR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
ACHIEVEMENT A BUSINESS HONOREE
MISS MAHDIA IS SILENUS. SYSTEM
WITH A. TEN ZERO CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU NEXT GEN THE SEQUENCE
THAT AT US SHE IS AN AWARD
WINNING FILMMAKER WHO BELIEVE
STORY TELLING IS MORE THAN JUST
CAPTURING AN AUDIENCE SHE
STRIVES TO CREATE MEANINGFUL
CONTENT USING THE PLATFORM AT
ESPN AND THAT'S MULTIPLE OUTLETS
HIS ILLUMINATED IMPORTANT ISSUES
THE TRADITIONAL MEDIA OFTEN
OVERLOOKED WITH MILLIONS OF
VIEWS HER POWER FORCE POWERFUL
STORYTELLING IS A BEACON FOR
ISSUES SUCH AS THE QUALITY
SYSTEMS- ASIDE PREVENTION AND
OTHER ISSUES SINCE STARTING AT
ESPN IN TWENTY TWELVE NUMEROUS
OTHER PROJECTS AND A DECORATED
MISQUOTE THAT US CAREER. THE
DIRECTOR PRODUCER A ONE TIME
AWARD WINNER ME AWARD WINNER
FIVE TIME EMMY NOMINEE AND TWO
TIME NEW YORK FESTIVALS WITH
SILVER MEDAL RECIPIENT AGAIN
PLEASE HONOR PLEASE WELCOME OUR
HONOR WE IN JOURNALISM AND MEDIA
MISS JENNA SEQUENCE THAT AT US.
NECURS ASIANS NEXT IS RON ERA.
HE HAS BEEN A UNION MEMBER FOR
OVER FORTY ONE YEARS AND
CURRENTLY SERVES AS PRESIDENT OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FEDERATION OF LABOR. THE L. A.
FED IS THE SECOND LARGEST LABOR
COUNCIL IN THE UNITED STATES
WITH OVER THREE HUNDRED
AFFILIATES AND EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKERS. HE STARTED HIS
UNION CAREER IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE AS A PACKAGE CAR DRIVER
WITH UPS WHERE HE REPRESENTED
HIS FELLOW MEMBERS AS A SHOP
STEWARD. THE TITLE THAT HE IS
MOST PROUD OF ABOVE ALL OTHERS.
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE HE WAS
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF LOCAL THREE
NINETY SIX AND CONTINUES TO BE
THE PRINCIPAL OFFICER OF THAT
LOCAL. IN TWENTY FIFTEEN HE WAS
ELECTED VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
WESTERN STATES THE FIRST LET THE
YOU KNOW ELECTED AS A NATIONAL
OFFICER IN OVER A HUNDRED YEARS
. DURING THE PANDEMIC HE LEADS
LABOR'S EFFORTS TO FEED THREE
QUARTER OF A MILLION POOR PEOPLE
THOUSANDS OF VACCINATIONS AND
MOBILE UNITS. AND PP TO AS FAR
AWAY AS OAKS OXNARD AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY THE FARMERS
CONGRATULATIONS TO PUBLIC
SERVICE HONOREE MISTER RON AND
ANNA. FOR MORE THAN FORTY YEARS
DR GUILLERMO VALENZUELA HAS HAS
HELPED THE LATINO COMMUNITY IN
THE INLAND EMPIRE A NATIVE OF
CHILE WHERE HE WAS RAISED IN
CHALLENGING. VERY CHALLENGING
ECONOMIC CIRCUMSTANCES HE BECAME
AN OBGYN PHYSICIAN AND THE BILL
THE WOMEN'S HEALTH DEPARTMENT
THAT SERVES CELEBRATE SAMBAR TO
DINO COUNTIES POOREST RESIDENTS
RESIDENTS HE IS FOCUSED ON
WOMEN'S HEALTH AND HEALTH CARE
ACCESS BECAUSE THE I. E. HAS THE
LOWEST PHYSICIAN PATIENT RATIO
IN CALIFORNIA. DOCTOR WELL AS
WELL- CURRENTLY OWN SEVEN
CLINICS WHERE TWENTY THOUSAND
FAMILIES RECEIVE CARE HE FOUNDED
THE BODIES THE WELLA. FAMILY
FOUNDATION AND THE HISPANIC
HEALTH INSTITUTE TO SUPPORT
PROGRAMS AND RESEARCH THAT
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF DIVERSE
POPULATIONS CONGRATULATIONS TO
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO HEALTH AND
SCIENCES HONOREE DR DIEM ALL
VIOLENCE WELLA. NEXT IS I READ
THE BLOOD SHE IS KNOWN AMONGST
US AS THE CHICLANA ACTIVIST. YES
SIR OF THE LATINO COMMUNITY
SINCE THE NINETEEN SIXTIES BORN
IN BOYLE HEIGHTS BUT IS LIVED IN
AND SAN FERNANDO VALLEY FOR OVER
FIVE DECADES SHE WAS PART OF THE
CHICANO MOVEMENT ORGANIZED SIDE
BY SIDE WITH SAYS SIDE AND THE
LOTUS WORD THAT. SHE'S DEDICATED
HER LIFE TO SO MANY ISSUES AND
JUST IS UNWILLING TO STOP HER
ACTIVISM SHE HELD A POSITION IN
THE ADMINISTRATION OF FORMER
JERRY BROWN FORMER GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN SERVING AS AN THE
SPECIAL ASSISTANT TO EXPEDITE
GOVERNMENT SERVICES SERVED EIGHT
YEARS AS THE FIRST MEXICAN
AMERICAN APPOINTED TO THE STATE
PERSONNEL BOARD. SHE WORKED HARD
TO REMOVE ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS IN
THE STATE CIVIL SERVICE SYSTEM
AND SHE SUBSEQUENTLY SERVED ON
THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS
BOARD. OVERSEEING UNION
NEGOTIATIONS AT THE STATE'S
COLLEGES UNIVERSITIES AND PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEMS REALLY SEE THAT
IS TO OUR TWENTY TWENTY TWO
PUBLIC SERVICE HONOREE MISS
IRENE THOUGHT. NEXT A GOOD
FRIEND GEORGE L. PLAZA. AN
ENTREPRENEUR PHILANTHROPIST AND
AUTHOR WHOSE WORK SPANS BUSINESS
AND CIVIC ACTIVITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA HE IS THE FOUNDER AND
CEO OF CORDOBA CORPORATION A
FULL SERVICE ENGINEERING FIRM
THAT SPECIALIZES IN THE DELIVERY
OF INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS IN
TRANSPORTATION EDUCATION WATER
AND ENERGY SECTORS. MR PLUS
CIVIC ENGAGEMENTS ENCOMPASS
LEADERSHIP IN OTHER FEELS
ACADEMIC ATHLETIC AND CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS HE IS THE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE CURRENTLY
SERVING AS PRESIDENT OF THE LOS
ANGELES MEMORIAL COLISEUM
COMMISSION HE IS ALSO THE CO
AUTHOR OF THE FORMATIVE BOOK
UNLESS YOU KNOW POLITICS.
POWERSHIFT HOW LATINOS IN
CALIFORNIA TRANSFORMED POLITICS
IN AMERICA. HE HAS SUCCEEDED IN
BUILDING A FIRST CLASS
ORGANIZATION NEEDS TELLS HIS
EMPLOYEES THAT IS NOT ONLY
CAPABLE OF COMPETING WITH
ANYBODY IN THE INDUSTRY BUT ALSO
MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN THE
COMMUNITY HE HAS RECEIVED MANY
MANY AWARDS AND SERVED ON MANY
APPOINTED POSITIONS. INCLUDING
USC'S ALUMNUS OF THE YEAR AWARD
MISTER GEORGE PLOT ARE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUSINESS AND
PHILANTHROPY HONOREE. NEXT I
WILL. PROUDLY AND SADLY
INTRODUCE A SPECIAL IN MEMORIAM
LATINO SPIRIT AWARD ON HONOREE
MISTER ALFRED THE S. IN FUNDING
. HE WAS PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THE COMMUNITY HOUSING
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEMS AND PLANNING
ASSOCIATION SHE'S BY IN MONTEREY
COUNTY IT'S LARGEST NONPROFIT
HOUSING ORGANIZATION UNDER IS
TWENTY THREE YEARS OF LEADERSHIP
CHEESE BUT BUILT AND RENOVATED
ALMOST TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES AND
APARTMENTS FOR LOW INCOME AND
MODERATE INCOME PEOPLE INS
MONTEREY SAN BENITO AND SANTA
CRUZ COUNTIES. MR THE AS AN
BONTA BECAME ONE OF THE REGION'S
MOST RECOGNIZED LEADERS AND
ADVOCATES FOR FARMWORKER AND LOW
INCOME FAMILIES HIS DEDICATION
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING ACCESS WAS
ROOTED IN HIS OWN FAMILY'S STORY
AS A SON OF IMMIGRANT
FARMWORKERS. HERE REPRESENTING
MR THE AS IN FUND THAT USES WIFE
SB THAT THE US IN FRONT THERE
AND HIS DAUGHTER GADI NONE NAVA.
WHO SHARED THIS MORNING MANY OF
THE STORIES THAT THE COMMUNITY
HAS BEEN SHARED WITH THEM ABOUT
HOW IMPORTANT MR DS IN FRONT AS
WORK WAS WAS WAS- PLEASE OF
APPLAUSE FOR. ARE MORE IN
MEMORIAM SPECIFIC MISTER ALFRED
D. AS IN FUNDING. UNABLE TO BE
US ARE THE PHONE SO ARE THEIR
OWN WHO DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO
SERVING OTHERS AS A SUBSTANCE
ABUSE COUNSELOR RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE DIRECTOR AND NOW SPECIAL
EDUCATION ADVOCATE HE BEGAN AN
ORGANIZATION FAUCET IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN WITH THE INTENTION OF
HELPING PARENTS LATINO PARENTS
OF CHILDREN WITH DISABILITIES ON
HOW TO NAVIGATE THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM HE HAS HELPED HUNDREDS OF
FAMILIES AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
AND ACROSS THE STATE OF AND IN
THE LAST TEN YEARS HE HELPED-
SUPPORTING THOSE PARENTS IN
EXERCISING THEIR RIGHTS THROUGH
THE MAZE OF EDUCATIONAL HEARINGS
AND LEGAL ROCEEDINGS I JOIN ME
IN THANKING ARE THE COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT HONOREE DR OF PHONES
SOLD BY THAT ON. AND ALSO UNABLE
TO BE WITH THIS IS SONIA MANZANO
SHE'S A FIRST GENERATION
MAINLAND PORTER RICAN RAISED IN
THE SOUTH BRONX. IN THE EARLY
SEVENTIES HE PARTICIPATED IN THE
CREATION OF A BROADWAY SHOW HIT
GODSPELL BEFORE BEING OFFERED AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE THE ROLE
OF MY IDEA ON SESAME STREET. THE
ROLE SHE IS MOST KNOWN FOR
THROUGH THAT ROLE SHE WENT ON TO
AFFECT THEM MILLIONS OF PARENTS
AND CHILDREN AND HELPED
INCORPORATE LATINO STORY LINES
THAT RESONATED WITH OUR DIVERSE
COMMUNITY. SHE RECEIVED THE
LIFETIME ACHIEVEMENT AWARD AT
THE FORTY THIRD ANNUAL DAYTIME
EMMYS. AND HAS RECEIVED FIFTEEN
M. MAYES FOR STAFF WRITING
SESAME STREET MISS MANZANO IS
ALSO ON AWARD WINNING
CHILDREN'S- CHILDREN'S BOOK
AUTHOR PLEASE JOIN ME IN A ROUND
OF APPLAUSE. FOR THEIR HER
ACHIEVEMENT IN ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT HONOREE MASANYA
MONTHS FINAL. AND FINALLY.
FINALLY WITH US CHEECH MUDDYING
A PARADOX IN THE WORLD OF
ENTERTAINMENT AN ACTOR A
DIRECTOR A WRITER A MUSICIAN ART
COLLECTOR AND HUMANITARIAN AND
MANY OTHER TITLES THAT WE GIVE
HIM. EACH IS BEST KNOWN AS HALF
OF THE SATIRICAL DUO CHEECH AND
CHONG WHO TOGETHER RELEASED
VARIOUS ALBUMS FIX BECAME GOLD
FOR WERE NOMINATED FOR GRAMMYS
AND LAW SCHOOL CHINOS ONE THE
NINETEEN SEVENTY THREE GRAMMY
FOR BEST COMEDY RECORDING HE HAS
ALSO STARTED EIGHT FEATURE
FILMS. ASIDE FROM TEACHERS
IMPRESSIVE FILM CAREER HE'S ALSO
RECOGNIZED TODAY AS A PRE
EMINENT CHICANO ART ADVOCATE HE
BEGAN DEVELOPING THE FINEST
PRIVATE COLLECTION OF CHICANO
ART IN THE EIGHTIES FURTHERING
HIS GOAL TO INTRODUCE CHICANO
ART TO A WIDER AUDIENCE. HE
ENTERED A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
CITY OF RIVERSIDE AND THE
RIVERSIDE ART MUSEUM TO CREATE
THE MARINE CENTER MIGHT MEAN
CENTER FOR CHICANO ART CULTURE
AND INDUSTRY SLATED TO OPEN NEXT
MONTH THE CHEESE WHICH YOU ARE
ALL INVITED TO ATTEND AND HELP
AND SUPPORT. THE CHEECH WILL
BECOME THE PERMANENT HOME FOR
HIS MORE THAN SEVEN HUNDRED
WORKS OF CHICANO ART CLEANING
PAINTINGS SCULPTURES PHOTOGRAPHY
COLLECTIVELY THE MOST RENOWNED
CHICANO ART COLLECTION IN THE
UNITED STATES AND I MUST SAY
PERSONALLY WHEN MANY OF US
THOUGHT THAT. THE POSTERS AND
THOSE WE ALL THOUGHT O IT AS
JUST SCRIBBLINGS HE RECOGNIZED
IN IT THAT IT WAS TRULY ART THAT
WE ALL SHOULD BE EXTRAORDINARY
PROUD OF PLEASE WELCOME OUR
GUEST MISTER CHEECH MARIN. AND
THAT'S THE END OF ALL OF OUR
HONOREES THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR DORADO AND
THANK YOU TO THE AWARDEES FOR
MAKING CALIFORNIA A BETTER
PLACE. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
RETURN TO SENATE THIRD READING
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM EIGHTY NINE SENATOR LA MON
PROCEED- MINUTES SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE RESOLUTION
EIGHTY THREE BY SENATOR LIMÓN.
RELATIVE TO LATINA ACTION DAY.
CEREMONY THANK YOU THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND SHIFTING JUST A
LITTLE BIT WITH THE EXCITEMENT
ANOTHER FORM OF EXCITEMENT I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT S. R. ONE O.
FOUR TO RECOGNIZE THIS WEEK AS
COMPOST AWARENESS WEEK. COMPOST
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT IN
PRODUCING THE AGRICULTURE
FANATICS CENTER LAVONE WE
ACTUALLY HAD YOU DOWN DOING OF
SENATE RESOLUTION NUMBER EIGHTY
THREE WELL I GOT THAT ONE TO YOU
THAT'S THE ONE WE'RE LOOKING
FOR. MADAM SECRETARY SAID THE
WHEN YOU READ. BEAUTIFUL PLEASE
PRESS WHEN YOU'RE READY SEVEN
LIMÓN THANK YOU ANOTHER EXCITING
AT RESOLUTION I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT S. R. EIGHTY THREE TO
RECOGNIZE TO DATE MAY SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY TWO AS LATINA
ACTION DATE. LATINAS HAVE HELD
SIGNIFICANT ROLES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY PHIL CASING
THEIR EXPERTISE AND EXCELLED IN
MANY DISCIPLINES INCLUDING THE
SCIENCES ARTS AND GOVERNMENT.
LETTING A LEADERS LIKE GLORIA
MOLINA IS. THE LOTUS WENT THAT
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE THE SUPREME
COURT OF CALIFORNIA BUT THE
SIGNAL AND OTHERS WHO HAVE BEEN
FIRST IN THEIR INDUSTRIES HAVE
INSPIRED. LATINA ACTION DATE. A
YEAR MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED THAT
THE NEST ALL OVER CALIFORNIA
CONVENE HERE IN SACRAMENTO FOR
LEVINE ACTION DAY AN ANNUAL
PUBLIC POLICY ISSUES CONFERENCE
ORGANIZED BY THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS. HOPE HE'S FINANCE
ORGANIZE FOR POLITICAL EQUALITY.
FOR TWENTY YEARS AND THIS ONE
DAY CONFERENCE HAS CREATED AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR DIALOGUE BETWEEN
CORPORATE COMMUNITY AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO DISCUSS CURRENT
ISSUES IN POLICIES AFFECTING
LATINOS LIVING IN CALIFORNIA.
THE CONFERENCE ALSO ALLOWS IN
LATINO LEADERS TO GAIN FIRST
HAND EXPERIENCE OF ADVOCACY BY
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH REPRESENTATIVES ON
ISSUES IMPACTING THEM AND THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THIS RESOLUTION
CALLS ON US TO CONTINUE TO
RECOGNIZE AND SUPPORT THE
EFFORTS OF SO MANY WHO IN ABLE
FUTURE GENERATIONS TO FOLLOW IN
THEIR FOOTSTEPS AND MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THIS COMMUNITY. AS
A GRADUATE OF HOPE BY NATIONAL
LEADERSHIP PROGRAM PLEASE JOIN
ME IN RECOGNIZING TODAY AS
LATINA ACTION DAY THANK YOU
CENTER LEMOND DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
ALSO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SR EIGHTY THREE AND I THINK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. I STAND
HERE TODAY ALONG WITH MY LATINA
COLLEAGUES ON THIS FLOOR CORE
HERE TO PROVIDE A VOICE FOR
LATINO COMMUNITIES. ESPECIALLY
ARE LATINOS WHO OFTENTIMES ARE
UNDERMINED AND LEFT OUT OF THE
DECISION MAKING TABLE. TODAY I
WANTED TO SHARE THAT IN MY
DISTRICT WHERE I REPRESENT AND
WE ALL REPRESENTS NEARLY ONE
MILLION INDIVIDUALS FOUR HUNDRED
AND SIXTY THOUSAND OF THEM ARE
WOMEN. TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND OF THOSE WOMEN OR
LATINAS SAY YET WHEN I RAN FOR
OFFICE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN WE HAD
ZERO LOT THE NASS ON THE STATE
SENATE FLOOR. AND AS I LOOK
AROUND I AM SO PROUD TO BE
SURROUNDED BY MY LATINA SISTERS
HERE TODAY WE'VE MADE STRIDES WE
PUSH THE ENVELOPE IN HERE WE ARE
AND THAT'S CONTINUE TO. KEEP
FIGHTING TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
REPRESENTATION AT ALL LEVELS
TODAY I ASKED MY SISTER MY HOPE
SISTERS TO KEEP INSPIRING KEEP
LEADING KEEP USING OUR
COLLECTIVE VOICE TO ADVANCE. OUR
COLLECTIVE POWER AND CONTINUE TO
ALSO INSPIRE THE NEXT GENERATION
OF LEADERS TO OUR WOMEN HONOREES
FOR THE LATINO SPIRIT AWARD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS. THANK YOU FOR
LEADING THANK YOU FOR HONORING
US WITH THE WORK THAT YOU DO AND
ALWAYS REPRESENTING US HONORABLY
SO TODAY I ASK MY COLLEAGUES ON
THIS FLOOR TO PLEASE. BE AN AYE
VOTE ON SR EIGHTY THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER RUBIO
CEREMONY WITH NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FEDERAL
MOGUL JUDGE CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
MEMBERS THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT CYLINDER LAYERED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NO EIGHTY BY AWAY. AND
NATURALLY TO. CENTER LAYERED
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF
SENATE BILL NINE EIGHTY TO ALLOW
THE CALIFORNIA APPLE COMMISSION
TO CREATE AN ORGANIC APPLE
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. A RIGHT
NOW- METAL CYCLOPROPANE MCP IS
IMPORTED. BY OUT OF STATE APPLE
GROWERS IT IS NOT REQUIRED-
THEY'RE NOT POSTING THAT IT'S
NON ORGANIC AND YET OUR OWN
APPLE GROWERS ARE POST HAVING TO
POST AT THIS IS ORGANIC THIS
WILL FIX THAT AND MAKE IT FAIR.
THEIR SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES NO
NO VOTES AND NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THE USER LAYERED MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTERMAN-
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT. OF THIS BILL HOW DO
YOU LIKE THEM APPLES. SENATOR.
FOR HOW DO YOU OF IT I DO I RISE
SUPPORT OF THIS MATTER WE HEARD
THIS IN- IN AG AND I THINK THIS
IS DEFINITELY THE RIGHT WAY TO
GO ANCAMAN THE AUTHOR FOR A
BRING THIS BILL. THANK YOU
CENTER PORGES MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
PORTANTINO. THERE'S ALWAYS ONE
BAD APPLE AT EVERY GALA. THANK
YOU FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING MANSON
EARLIER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF THE BAD
SEEDS THAT SPOKEPROPER SHOULD
THE DEBATE AND I ASKED FOR
NOVELS THANK YOU CENTER LAYERED
MEMBERS THIS IS ALSO- QUALIFIES
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION USE UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS
THIRTY SIX NO ZERO. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
REMOVED A FILE ITEM EIGHTY THREE
SENATOR HER TADO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NINE HUNDRED BY SENATOR HER
TADO AN ACT RELATING TO TRIBAL
GAMING AND DECLARING THE URGENCY
THERE OF SIX MEDIALLY. CENTER
HER TADO. THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT- ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
HUNDRED THE VEHICLE TO RATIFY
THE TRIBAL STATE GAMING COMPACT
BETWEEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND TWO INDIAN TRIBES THE SANTA
ROSA RANCHERIA TETCHY TRIBE IN
THE MILTON RANCHERIA POMO
INDIANS OF CALIFORNIA. ALL SPEAK
TO THE AGREEMENT WITH THE TECH
TO TRY BECAUSE IT'S- UP WITH
CASINO IS IN MY DISTRICT FOR
DECADES APACHE TRIBE HAS BEEN A
VALUABLE PARTNER IN THE KINGS
COUNTY COMMUNITY. THE TRY
PROVIDE SCHOLARSHIP ASSISTANCE
JOB TRAINING AND ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAMS HEALTH AND WELFARE
ASSISTANCE AND OTHER SOCIAL
SERVICES. IN ADDITION THE
TROUBLE BE PROVIDING NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND GOOD WILL
TO KINGS COUNTY THROUGH. AN
INTER GOVERNMENTAL AGREEMENT AND
WILL BE PROVIDE HALF THE
EXPENSES FOR MAINTENANCE OF THE
FIRE STATION. AS FOR THE TRIBE
HAS BEEN THE DEFINITION OF A
GOOD NEIGHBOR THE LANGUAGE IN
THE COMPACT IS SUBSTANTIALLY THE
SAME AS RECENT COMPACTS REFLECTS
NECESSARY CHANGES TO THE
AGREEMENT FOR FEDERAL APPROVAL.
ONE OF THE CHANGES TO THE
CONTACT WITH THE TROUBLING TO
CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE RELATING TO
THE ENFORCEMENT OF TRIBAL
RELATIONS LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE THE TRIBE. DID THIS
EVEN THOUGH THERE HAS NEVER BEEN
A LABOR ISSUE AT THE PROPERTY.
THEY BRING INTERVIEW TO ON BOTH
OF THESE COMPACT THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION ON THE FILE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASPEN ABOUT. THE
CENTER HER TADO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE. THIS IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
ANY OBJECTION. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IS THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY I WAS THIRTY
SIX NEWS NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM EIGHTY EIGHT SENATOR
LAMONT ADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE OH FOUR BY
SENATOR LIMÓN RELATIVE TO
COMPOST AWARENESS WEEK CEREMONY.
THANK YOU MEMBERS NEVER REALLY
ON TO COMPOST I AM PROUD TO
PRESENT S. R. ONE O. FOUR TO
RECOGNIZE THIS WEEK AS COMPOST
AWARENESS WEEK WHERE WE TALK
BOTH ABOUT APPLES AND WORMS.
COMPOST IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
IN PRODUCING THE AGRICULTURE
PRODUCTS CALIFORNIA IS WELL
KNOWN FOR LIKE THREE WEEKS
STRAWBERRIES AND CITRUS.
IRRIGATED CROPLAND IN THE STATE
USES SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION
TONS OF BULL COMPOST ANNUALLY.
COMPOST HELPS PROVIDE THE PLANTS
WITH MORE NUTRIENTS BUT IT ALSO
INCREASES WATER RETENTION
IMPROVES WATER QUALITY AND
SEQUESTERS CARBON. COMPOSTED
EVEN BEING USED TO PREVENT
EROSION AFTER WILDFIRES. THIS
YEAR'S THEME IS A RECIPE FOR
REGENERATION COMPOST TO FOCUS
NOT ONLY ON THE BENEFITS FOR
HEALTHY SOILS AND CROPS BUT ALSO
HAVE COMPOST CAN HELP. US THE
QUEST FOR CARBON AND DIVERT MORE
WASTE FROM LANDFILLS I HOPE YOU
CAN ALL JOIN ME IN CELEBRATING
COMPOST AWARENESS WEEK. THANK
YOU CENTER LIMÓN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING THEN THIS IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY FIVE SENATOR BATES. MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL NINE TWENTY FIVE BY SENATOR
BASS AN ACT RELATING TO FADE AVE
KILLER ACCIDENTS. CENTER BATES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
TO PRESENT SENATE BILL NINE
TWENTY FIVE. WHICH WILL HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT UNDERSTAND AND
QUANTIFY THE CAUSES BEHIND FATAL
COLLISIONS CURRENTLY LOCAL
CORONERS AND MEDICAL EXAMINERS
ARE REQUIRED TO TEST DECEASED
DRIVERS AND PASSENGERS WERE
ALCOHOL CONTENTS BUT NOT FOR
DRUG CONTENT. WITH THE
LEGALIZATION OF RECREATIONAL
MARIJUANA AND THE RISE OF OPIOID
ABUSE MANY NEW DRUG MANY NEW
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE
CASES ARE DUE TO DRUG USE NOT
JUST ALCOHOL. WE ARE THE
LEGISLATURE NEED ACCURATE DATA
ON THE CAUSE OF A FATAL
COLLISIONS ACROSS THE STATE SO
WE CAN MAKE SOUND EVIDENCE BASED
POLICIES. 
ADDITIONAL TOOLS TO UNDERSTAND
AND PREVENT FUTURE COLLISIONS SB
NINE TWENTY FIVE WILL UPDATE
CURRENT LAW TO REQUIRE DRUG
TESTING IN ADDITION TO ALCOHOL
TESTING AFTER FATAL COLLISIONS
REFLECTING ACCURATELY THE MODERN
USE OF PRESCRIPTION AND
RECREATIONAL DRUGS. THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES TESTING IN THE
CASE OF THE DEATHS THAT OCUR
WITHIN FORTY EIGHT HOURS OF THE
COLLISION INSTEAD OF JUST TWENTY
FOUR HOURS CAPTURING
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE DATA ON FATAL
COLLISIONS THE BILL IS. THE
REINTRODUCTION OF S. B. TWO
EIGHTY THREE FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
WHICH PASSED UNANIMOUSLY OFF
THIS FLOOR OF THE BILL WAS HELD
IN ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
BECAUSE THERE WERE CONCERNS FROM
THE OPPOSITION TO THOSE CONCERNS
HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED. AND THERE
ISN'T ANY OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ANY OBJECTION. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IS THIRTY SIX NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
TO FILE ITEM SIXTIES- PORTANTINO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TEN OH TWO BY
SENATOR PORTANTINO AN ACT. OF
VIOLATING TO WORKERS
COMPENSATION SO A PORTANTINO
THANK YOU AYE MADAM. AND
SENATORS I'M PRESENTING SP ONE
THOUSAND TWO WHICH LOOKS TO
ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE OF
BEHAVIORAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS IN THE WORKERS
COMP SYSTEM. INJURED WORKERS
MUST OFTEN WAIT FOR EXTENSIVE
TIME PERIODS BEFORE SEEKING FULL
PSYCHIATRIC TREATMENT DUE TO A
SCARCITY OF AVAILABLE
PSYCHIATRIC OR PSYCHOLOGICAL
PROVIDERS. THIS DELAY IN MENTAL
HEALTH CARE AND EVALUATION OFTEN
RESULTS IN INJURED WORKERS
DELAYED RETURN TO WORK AND
INCREASED COSTS TO THE SYSTEM SB
ONE THOUSAND TO AUTHORIZES
QUALIFIED LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKERS. TO PROVIDE
ASSESSMENT CONSULTATION TO
INJURED WORKERS SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL OR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
ISSUES THEREBY PROVIDING
ADDITIONALLY ADDITIONAL AND
READILY AVAILABLE RESOURCES
WITHIN THEIR LICENSURE. TO
INJURED WORKERS IN NEED OF
IMMEDIATE MENTAL HEALTH CARE BY
INCLUDING LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKERS IN MEMBER
PROVIDER NETWORKS SB ONE
THOUSAND TWO HAS THE OPTIONAL.
OPTION TO ADD TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND LICENSED CLINICAL
SOCIAL WORKERS TO HELP MEET THE
DEMANDS PRESENTED DURING KERR
CURRENT MENTAL. THIS AND I
RESPECTFULLY. THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NUMBER VERSUS IS ALSO
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION. SEEING
HEARING NONE IS THIRTY SIX ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES REMOVING THE
FILE ITEM SIXTY THREE SENATOR
MEN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
. SENATE BILL TWELVE NINETY NINE
BY SENATOR MAN AN ACT RELATING
TO PEOPLE INSTRUCTION CENTERMAN
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT SB
TWELVE NINETY NINE WHICH EXTENDS
A SUNSET DATE FOR AN IMPORTANT
ACADEMIC PROGRAM PROVIDED BY THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA. KNOWN AS
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SUMMER
SCHOOL IN MATHEMATICS AND
SCIENCE PROGRAM OR COSMOS
SPECIFICALLY TWELVE IN SB TWELVE
NINETY NINE EXTENDS A SUNSET
DATE FOR THE CUSTOMER PROGRAM
BACK BY FIVE YEARS ENSURING THAT
IT CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
CRUCIAL EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ACROSS THE STATE.
BECAUSE MOST PROGRAM PROVIDES AN
INTENSE ACADEMIC EXPERIENCE FOR
STUDENTS WHO WISH TO LEARN OR
BETTER THEMSELVES IN ADVANCED
MATHEMATICS SCIENCE BIOLOGY AND
ENGINEERING PREPARING THEM FOR
FUTURE CAREERS IN THESE
RESPECTIVE AREAS. THIS FOUR WEEK
RESIDENTIAL ACADEMIC PROGRAM
PROGRAM IS LOCATED AT FOUR
CAMPUSES UC DAVIS UC SAN DIEGO
UC SANTA CRUZ AND UC SURVIVE YOU
SEE IRVINE WHICH I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF REPRESENTING. SB
TWELVE NINETY NINE WHEN IT SURE
THAT THE COSMOS PROGRAM SET TO
EXPIRE AT THE END OF THIS YEAR
CAN CONTINUE TO SHAPE THE LIVES
OF YOUNG STUDENTS- BY EXTENDING
THE PROGRAM AND BY INCREASING
THE MAXIMUM APPLICATION TUITION
FEES CONSISTENT WITH PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION. ALLOWING IT TO
CONTINUE TO BE INCREASED NO
HIGHER THAN 5% ANNUALLY OR THE
AVERAGE RATE OF INFLATION.
CLARIFY THE CONSISTENT WITH
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION THIS BILL
SETS THE MAXIMUM RATE THAT YOU
SEE BORDER REGIONS CAN CHARGE
STUDENTS. THIS IS A CEILING AND
NOT A FLOOR. THIS BILL IS
CRUCIAL TO ENSURING THAT THE
COSMOS PROGRAM CAN CONTINUE TO
INSPIRE STUDENTS EXPAND PATHWAYS
TO HIGHER EDUCATION. AND
STRENGTHEN OUR STATE'S FUTURE
WORKFORCE PARTICULARLY AMONG
YOUNG GIRLS AND WOMEN WHO ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED NEEDS FEELS.
THIS BILL SPONSORED BY
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
MEANT MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS THIS IS ALSO YOU FELT
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION. SEEING
NONE IS THIRTY EIGHT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES REMOVING THE FILE
ITEM THIRTY NINE SENATOR BY CAL
SKI MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ. I HAD A RONI'S INFORMATION
FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX NO. ONE
MOMENT.
MEMBERS ARE A LITTLE CONFUSION
THERE WE ARE BACK TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY NINE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL NINE
TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI NACTA RELATING TO
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS CENTER BY
CAL SKI MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS
THIS MEASURE WILL INCREASE THE
MINIMUM FEE THAT IS PAID TO
PUBLIC ADMINISTRATORS- FROM ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHO ARE PUBLIC
ADMINISTRATORS THERE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES THE WORK THEY'D
MINISTRY TO A STATE EITHER THAT
HAVE NO WILLS OR NO LIVING
RELATIVES AT ONE ADMINISTRATOR
ADMINISTRATIVE STATES THE
COUNTIES. GENERALLY LOSE A LOT
OF MONEY AND TO LOSE A LITTLE
LESS MONEY AND- TONIGHT BOTH
THANK YOU CENTER BY CAL SKI
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS
IS ALSO ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. THE AND HEARING THEM
I START SIX NO ZERO THE MAY
PASSED. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. IS THERE
ANYTHING ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
TAKE OFF OR HAVE REMOVED FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NO ONE WILL TAKE UP THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR FIRST
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE THIRTEEN AND ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY
EIGHT THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE CHECKER AYE FORGES AYE
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE FOR
TESTING AYE DALY. DODD HI
TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HI HERTZBERG
FIVE WEST SO. I FURTADO HI JONES
I KAMLAGER LAYERED I LEYVA AYE
LIMÓN AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELINDA'S
AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN. I NIELSEN
AYE TELEVOTE AYE PAN PORTANTINO
I ROTH AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE I'M BURKE HI MY
CASTING AYE WIENER AYE WILK.
HIGHS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN
ADOPTED MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO
FURTHER BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION WILL BE SCHEDULED FOR
THIS THURSDAY MAY FIFTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO AT NINE AM. THANK YOU
MAN APPROACHED HIM MEMBERS THE
SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED AND WE
WILL RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE
AM HAVE A GREAT REST OF THE DAY.